I I hunted them down climbed that
mountain even I thought you guys were
friends I remember you like didn't make
it public that you guys were together
yeah and I was like what a cool
friendship
but you know what it kind of worked out
how professional they were because a lot
of guys just probably want to hit on jio
but they end up somehow collaborating
with JK in hopes of like getting closer
to Geo yeah
[Applause]
that's awesome
I'm comfortable you could just see guys
like I had chatted up with you on set
between cakes I don't think Bart gets
uncomfortable I don't really care
I'm not gonna reciprocate it I'm not
very like jealous like that it was a big
guy that was hitting on Geo in Santa
Monica and he was laughing about it he
wouldn't step in we were walking he kept
following me trying to talk to me and
this guy kept flying I actually walked
away black dude so as he was coming this
way I started walking that way
what'd you do I don't know I remember
what I did but he got the point I like
seeing that out of it that's hot oh she
likes seeing you walk away too that's
super hot